how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything
relating to the mcu and speaking of the
mcu
something very very strange but also
very
awesome has happened today universes are
colliding in
spider-man 3. as we have official news
that a character from the amazing
spider-man with andrew garfield is
making his way
over to spider-man 3 with tom holland
coming straight from the hollywood
reporter their headlines for this
article reads
spider-man 3 jolt jamie foxx returning
as
elektro and then they say how is that
for shocking and it is absolutely
shocking as
these two movies the amazing spider-man
movies and tom
holland spider-man do not exist in the
same universe although kevin feige did
say that tom holland's spider-man is the
only character that has the ability to
jump different universes but the article
goes on to say
the next spider-man movie is getting a
major jolt jamie foxx who played classic
spidey villain electro in the andrew
garfield starring the amazing spider-man
2
is in final talks to reprise the role
for the latest spider-man installment
starring tom holland and being made by
marvel studios and
sony pictures now this could be all the
evidence that we need
that the sinister 6 is in fact coming
for spider-man 3.
otherwise why bring electro that was
played by jaime foxx and the amazing
spider-man 2
over to the mcu and have him play the
same
exact role in this movie so it
definitely seems like this is going to
be either
a sinister 6 debut in spider-man 3 or a
definite setup for them in a future
spider-man film
however there could be another
explanation to this by the time that
spider-man 3 comes out the multiverse
will be blown up in the mcu
and when it comes to the multiverse
there really aren't that many rules and
it enables you to do many
many different types of things including
bringing a character from one universe
into
another and it seems like this has
actually already been confirmed with jay
jonah jameson
jay jonah jameson played by jk simmons
who was in the original spider-man
trilogy
popped up at the end of spider-man far
from home seemingly making a universe
jump so if jamie foxx's electro
is actually coming from a different
universe he won't be the first character
to make that jump to the mcu but what we
could be seeing here
is the repercussions of the snap and the
blip
as spider-man far from home called it
this could somehow create a
universe rift in which some people could
be snapped back into different universes
either way production for spider-man 3
is months away right now so we'll have
to wait just a little bit to find out
what's really going on here but it
really does seem like the multiverse is
actually going to play a pretty big role
in spider-man 3 especially if you
consider that they set it up in
spider-man far from home where peter
parker and mysterio
were talking about the multiverse now of
course mysterio was lying about the
multiverse but we know that it is going
to be introduced in phase 4.
but let me know your thoughts and let me
know your theories on this what do you
think about jamie foxx's electro from
the amazing spider-man 2 with andrew
garfield now coming to the mcu
and playing elektra with tom holland and
spider-man 3. let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below and don't
forget to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest mcu news and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a cyclops funko pop for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you